oh yeah [ __ ] huh we're just separate
which my girlfriend's here so I only got
a limited down a time to play let's get
this in will make sure no I'm into women
look like Bobby I'm on where you [ __ ] I
just invited you there you are
alright ready it up this is the truth
right here wfe
I haven't seen Griffin plate [ __ ] pub
gee I'm excited
yep this is not gonna go well
just grab loop for us that's it
wait I don't want to look too fat on
camera there we go there we go so you're
like all right you're like in lost in
space Griffin yeah I think it's pretty
good I think it looks really good yeah
I'm eating all that for all that for
case she looks good on Netflix
yeah but the visual effects the
production is on like if you have a 4k
if you've a 4k TV you're in that you're
in you're in but I got my issues but I
can't say them cuz you know it's like
spoiler alert or something how do you
know Craig no I watch the show I'm on
episode 6 what episode are you on at all
how many episodes are there 10 wait how
do I see my chat I don't the [ __ ] app
for twitch on the computer if the
desktop version is so stupid okay Oh
included their audio by the way the
cheeky they have the audio I'm using my
what do you wanna do what do you want
land pinky who's this girl but Tinky's
too wild it's too wild for us what about
no [ __ ] right there
Volvo dairies don't know let's go no no
no the yellow oh well you gotta tell me
we didn't need go go towards where that
mark - don't don't just [ __ ] fly - oh
oh oh [ __ ] I kind of do that right I can
see that already
oh my god where
yellow you gotta get it there you go
trip see the chatroom I see there you go
I'll show you my parachute oh [ __ ]
I'll be a outskirts Northside you see
anybody oh I got one yeah see one lining
towards me there you go the houses wait
water tower yeah I got that
no just follow the go to a Griffin water
tower there's not a big house on the
hill bottom of the hill oh my god okay I
got it
how do you climb [ __ ] again these games
how do you other games I play better
games than this stupid piece of [ __ ] if
we weren't playing together no one would
play this game by themselves okay this
is like the worst game on all the time I
have a sickle oh I hear I hear something
I see some [ __ ] over where are
you
they're all near me
I hear them all around me there's
nothing here this is the dumbest house
Sammy that's like mattresses and [ __ ]
here I'm gonna go upstairs already rated
that [ __ ] coke already rated that house
there's nothing here man
that Coke rated it took everything oh
there's a crossbow equip this possible
wait how do you switch weapons again
yeah okay wait truce
who's shooting is that you where is that
I'm shooting all my trees of peace
there's a goddamn eye right behind this
red house crossbow oh there's another
something here for anybody wants it how
do you get out here I see another
handgun got a shotgun here we go
have no idea how do you do that's
[ __ ] [ __ ] achill could they give
me a [ __ ] regular gun it's [ __ ]
guys upstairs somebody's come house
where are you guys oh my god you guys
are so far away from me now huge guns
again how did he take as much as he did
I don't know it's all I had was coming
toward this gun
I can't even load this gun oh my god all
I hear is shooting how do you get a
handgun to go press up to pull out your
handgun
oh there we go just [ __ ] I'm gonna quit
this be me I have a beanie on nice
goodbye the tree we're all you guys hey
Griff it's talking about bees and [ __ ]
there's a plane coming there's someone
here the coke underneath me there's like
a dune buggy right here well there's a
guy right here I'm gonna get him get him
get him yeah that guy there you go there
you go Griffin oh [ __ ] finally yes we
got that on camera I'm finally doing
what you didn't kill [ __ ] any guy
right here
stealing is good right now I got another
you did yeah missing X but it's not
working what the hell is bodies move get
up hold it dancer I'm holding it it's
not working you got a duck down are you
on the ground next to it yes dynasty I
don't know can you help get this oh my
god how come I can't loot this [ __ ]
why's Craig getting frustrated cuz she's
asking and I'm not in the game so I
can't help okay you're in the game oh my
god
okay watch something how do you get rid
of [ __ ]
pick up the other there you go go to the
box go to the box
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
get inside get in here in the right
you're in the red though the bombs are
gonna I'm in the red oh [ __ ] what you
don't know how I'm getting this get in
the house it doesn't that's not gonna
save you I don't have the ammo for this
gun yeah you do oh yeah get some hell do
you have any health you got to heal up
all your endless no wait wait wait
tonight
oh okay see okay I want to switch to
this and I'm gonna take this 12-gauge
shotgun okay right sure I don't know
what you do it I don't want this guy on
the job in like a
spectating watch it here we go I got a
decent gun now I got a decent guy make
sure it's on auto Griffin it's on auto I
can't pick up gasps Oh dpad talking
about I know well you'll get it
eventually but you gotta go with the
boys
I feel all right
right there folders to your right
dude right there well it's not [ __ ] yeah
all right somewhere work with you you
guys are gonna watch out don't go to the
blue line because it's too for you if
you need it oh my god what are you doing
no he needs something what are you doing
or about [ __ ] I give you an X Y AB USB
press B or B whatever it is B well I got
a motorcycle right here so you need to
understand this yeah bring that
motorcycle over
we gotta go guys yeah horrible
where we going go to your left go to
your left you got to go to the street
now do your right stopping me from going
okay this game is stupid all right you
gotta go okay where we going no no
across that Street no where you going
okay go straight go straight Oh
see where they are I see where they are
oh my god this is a nightmare it's
awesome it's awesome that you know
you're going to [ __ ] and you should hit
them when you get there keep going keep
going
cross the bridge just follow the road
now I gotta say they are missing you
like oh you every shot because I'm not
driving straight like a [ __ ] that's
true
alright now you gotta go to your right
to meet the guys say that's been motion
there's no [ __ ] would be good to get out
and loot this [ __ ] with them Griffin
fresh beat there's nothing here man
I said I can finally breathe man I can
breathe let Griffin go with them get out
of the buggy and go with them it's
easier yeah I get in the back cus be
recipe
without me I thank God you don't get a
turbo oh my god this Wow
I can't believe my car still driving I
know we told you to jump in with us
oh I can't believe this is still working
right now it's pretty impressive
actually
I got a way out a tire yeah Ryze [ __ ]
away I'm just gonna go straight towards
the yellow I can't move this car still
going
I know it's doing pretty good oh oh [ __ ]
oh oh wow I don't know how different
survived this long to be honest it's
kind of amazing watching this because
I'm not like being a [ __ ] like you
[ __ ] dick you gotta get to the low I
got Nate times
this [ __ ] I can't sleep I'll fall away
these [ __ ] off I still need that treat
well your your targets will have that
wheel the best part is when you honk
every time you start it up so people
know where you're at that's the best
part
so it's their work difference coming
from they were over there and that big
green arm place that he passed I you
should get out you guys in here yeah oh
[ __ ] you guys passed the [ __ ] circle
you have to go all the way back we
didn't know yeah oh my god huh
Grif if you want to run faster hold why
oh that's right oh here's the bike over
here Jeep sport all right so what do I
do here yeah yeah sex there you go
but I can't shoot my gun no you can't
because you're the [ __ ] hey Griffin you
can pull your handgun by pressing up on
the d-pad then you can shoot that let's
see oh sweet okay
I shoot coconut back of the head you can
this is like the worst [ __ ]
but you guys look awesome though oh this
is crazy I can't even believe have
people watching this soon says take a
drink every time how you and I are have
you guys here we go to the farm that's
pretty good what we're so far off it's
ridiculous no you're right there ya go
there it in the circle we're in it yeah
right now we're in the circle right
there there's a jeep right there I know
but I'm not fun that means something's
been looted keep going right that's what
I'm saying
what's that right there that a
motorcycle oh it is yeah it's been
looted oh it's been looted I didn't know
you could store stuff in the motorcycle
yeah what does that mean no not the
motorcycle that little Hutton do it
ready there we go Oh who's this hot mama
witness
[Laughter]
this helmet [ __ ] micro is that the
only guy up there coke cuz Griffin I
don't know I only saw this guy still
alive or in his own I gotta lose his
[ __ ] yeah he's okay where's the backpack
oh [ __ ] in his bag all right I'm gonna
take their where I don't see the
backpack well he had it on why isn't it
the first [ __ ] thing I don't know oh
here we go there we go police backpack
got it we're in the zone
wait did somebody take the [ __ ] that I
just picked up DP 29 well how come is
disappearing every time I it's probably
coke cuz coke just gab grabbed it off
right in front of you trifa get that
backpack you want 7.6 no you're good I
got 7.6 y'all need be careful there
might still be a dude up there I know
wait I need to sue now do I need to use
my bandages I think that might is there
might be now I gotta clear handy juice
you might have jumped out no upstairs
I'm going up the stairs there's a guy
who just shot me yeah I'm coming out
I'm getting girls enough cover me
yeah coffee oh Jesus Christ I'm having a
heart attack right now some bandages
okay how do I do oh [ __ ] I pissed the
wrong button
okay wait use if you use [ __ ]
bandages if you have an energy good
energy drink
do you have pills painkiller know what I
was pushing on him trying to kill him
you might told him I'm on it just being
gung-ho I did say it Craig Craig still
busy spectating just watching I've been
helping the whole time you didn't even
know how to bandage three meals ago
watch out Craig's helping goddamnit
I stopped how do you get down now don't
go down just just just protect coke no
I'm saying how do you kneel down he's
down sue do you right in my line of fire
now what do you want to do you want me
to kill you what is this a good position
I'm gonna [ __ ] Griffen Griffen toko
you can't just leave man I said we're
going ok well I'm with you let's go why
are we running
we can't get a car well you're right
outside the circle right there you're
right there Krypton where you going I'm
going to the worst my chat room right
now oh my god he's gonna die in the
circle if he doesn't move that guy's
gotta move toward you oh he's got this
but hold on Levi would you shoot him or
he's gonna let him get killed no left
side buggy that buggy is coming right
for you
what's a Jeep Jeep kill that the Jeep
vs. ded yo jump there's no one in there
yeah oh they probably Trek before it go
get it why he's right by the circle got
nine people there
oh why I lasted a long time then huh
yeah you guys were in here they're
driven that's why you had to get out of
the circle small you check the map okay
well there was if we had a proper leader
you know who's the leader
but it's pretty nice it sounds like
Yvonne Drago just like it was I go
Yvonne tomato I say tomorrow is he
selling yeah it's hard to shoot people
he's not even looking at the person game
is its horst yeah it's hard to shoot
it's like real life yeah you got your
lead bullet drop both distance speed
here we go that guy you got sideways
yeah stephannie left seven left I think
you should get that Jeep and just run
[ __ ] over how he's still moving on
the left there yeah he's dead
Wow six alive that means what I don't I
don't trust this tour did you get the
guy on the right sharpie I'll be right
here oh right there he's so lost
how is the worst feeling [ __ ] down
push push I'll just abort is the end
inside this room Oh beyond you talking
about what are you taught you heard you
just hi dude you're starting drama for
coke behind you
Greg that's your strategy I don't I
don't yell it out unless I see them the
whites of their eyes oh my god I'm so
sorry everyone that's listening to this
nonsense I did that also all my thing
how you can like what is it all on the
the twitch thing and you could stream
for extreme somebody else's stream
what's that called my hosting be quiet
be quiet be quiet
he's in the house coat he's right there
yeah I know I know
walk to the lads on the second floor by
the back it was a second window to the
left up top oh we did it though that was
good it was good all right who wants to
I get break the Franks should join in
who's out I can take a break even though
I didn't get much play that game
[Laughter]
all right you want to take my place
Frank I'm sorry for Bolger that you can
play with the boys invited me to the
last one I'll be back where I'll have to
start
we can't start you should we cancel
matchmaking [ __ ]
Frank's not in will jump out would you
hey you
my old friend cuz we're gonna win why
the [ __ ] didn't find joy piece of [ __ ]
I can't just talk into your controller
and tell it what to do yeah I do this
isn't like Siri add me to battle ground
well I mean no are you guys gotta send
me the invite
yeah we're let me see what I got here
all right
okay I got one more game in me press and
hold the start press hold start okay
exit to lobby the lobby go confirm I'm
gonna go get an iced tea
differently yeah we got to jump out we
had to jump out of the party oh really
group yeah it's about the group because
the fourth guy still with us we're in
the lobby
now sender no way we're still going at
this guy yeah it's just fatal error
pre-release software thanks you for
participating
okay web solo it
oh if you got that fatal error I would
restart the game and then in this game
twice I can't control people get mad
about that
it's girthy it's a chose certain like a
coffee mug
so Griffin wins a special again I'm not
to say yet I know that I don't want to
say publicly because all right but
you're gonna have a nice ooh we're gonna
have yes I could say is it'll be in June
I can say that
all right nice that's just coming off
fast there farm now [ __ ] the foul right
there
when yeah yo Tommy when yep yeah well
cut will tell you what lane with no flux
itself from babysitting you know you got
a [ __ ] like four marks which one are
we going to oh my god there's gonna be a
slaughter there's gonna be a squad here
be ready Wow no of course is gonna be a
guy there's a guy there's a guy at the
big house there's a guy landing right
next to oh my god wait wait wait oh this
guy's [ __ ] [ __ ] to a tree yeah
[ __ ] huh
Frankie's mouth heading towards you guys
we gotta exit to lobby eggs-it to lobby
light them up I have no guns there's a
guy across spoke okay I'm going across
like a I'll show everybody's I hate him
guys here it cook yep
Oh tails provide that free games with
pine April 1st to April 30th Oh clean
offer that's pretty good add it to your
switcher Kevin's gonna go shopping now
dev Wars three games fortnight oh cheese
go to epic games to link your epic and
twitch account make sure okay let's go
to this are you in the attorneys that
will be Griffin peace let's go on pack
you get this guy said you're in the new
Tarantino movie
if you're holding out on us all right
where we going
[Music]
we keep doing that would say looking
down from outside there we go so we go
to the power plant go to the PowerPoint
yeah power plant is yasna we just got an
out we're going to a power plant
breakfast uh-huh
many people are dropping come on there
give me jump yet I think a lot go
towards the mark drop reading right now
a fortnight [ __ ] fortnight a game sucks
yeah that's what you said about this
game now you're [ __ ] addicted [ __ ]
yeah but fortnight I'll never give a
[ __ ] that piece it I [ __ ] hate that
game Griffin you will not like that game
I played it I play that building
yeah I'm following the [ __ ] thing
what do you where am I going
thank you I'm at this new that this
power plant oh god there's a guy right
here yeah what the [ __ ] oh my god
okay survive that's it you were knocked
out from falling I died from falling
okay I'm in like I'm dead like you can't
I'm floating in air like I'm not even on
the ground it's not a good start do you
see oh my god you have to go this is
ridiculous hey people watching this
classic Griffin my gosh classic Griffin
when I see your ass again god I'm dying
yes I'm floating in air this is
ridiculous I don't even know where I am
or how this even happen are people
watching you do anything you're not sure
they are I see you yeah you're like on
top of something yeah oh wow okay okay
look I want some kind of this is crazy
what you see this video no no you're
dead no I got a tree knocked oh you died
finally what just happened the eight
times
helping just die yeah it's a glitch it
says dude this game is this game got to
get now this gun it's just floating in
there okay there we go oh I had a level
three vest [ __ ] I almost [ __ ] that up
I got best over here if anybody wants
them yeah I got an eight-time scope so
if somebody gets a four times that's how
swap I got a four times but I kind of
want the four times all right then I'll
keep T eight times
how about that but I almost feel like I
should take the four times are the eight
times because you definitely aren't
gonna hit [ __ ] with it so come on I'm
not giving it to you no [ __ ] are you got
a game I don't give you [ __ ] skull
for nothing [ __ ] no I okay I just said I
was gonna give you money you [ __ ]
idiot you bastards are in the middle of
battle and this is what you're gonna
fight about literally the worst fire to
nibble on it no no you want a suck-up
suck-up because you want this for time
well now a times now you guys stay at
the same time I can't even use it
[ __ ] oh look at that you got so much to
play with well here I'll come give it to
you I'll come give it to me the farm
in French over here all by himself
here's their it's on an oh here I'll
drop I'm gonna elope a hollow there's a
holograph I'm fine
take it don't ever don't ever talk down
to me again where are you I swear to God
come here you know you know I got
another red dot
how does my voice become like your voice
just more shrill and doesn't make much
sense I just I don't have any Chu I
don't have any to otherwise I try to do
the clothes
[Applause]
this should give me a brain aneurysm
you're [ __ ] lose all motor parts the
screen one Sunday that haven't done a
bit of walking being you know I just got
like you can play so you can play for
tonight on the on your laptop right yeah
I'm sure PC you can play it on on your
cuz I just got it for the Playhouse
haven't you guys rated I don't know man
I
I've only rated the couple cuz I got
pretty much everything I need
I'm curious though are you point when
you play online on a computer is it a
whole different server yeah yeah it's
not the same it's not the same as
taluses they're separate like the app
app is different nah dude because it
council people get [ __ ] over dude with
a keyboard and mouse
especially in fortnight with buildings
eh yeah it is I [ __ ] hate it
over here that's a regular car that we
could take bother getting shot drunk
yeah
yes [ __ ] it's a servants it's absurd
you got a what I said yeah you got a car
I'll be right there I'm just trying to
see if there's yeah I see that a Jeep
over here soon but I'm trying to just
move towards the circle are you already
out or not communicate yeah [ __ ] I
really need it looks like I couldn't
waste my breath and tell Craig what I'm
doing but he's not gonna do what I am I
can't really no point I'm coming to pick
you guys up and also pub G play your new
phone
oh wow for me it's boring with the
building [ __ ] Frank just ran into
the car what would like [ __ ] strength
who me yeah you just ran right into the
car I'm watching yeah I know it's a pain
get over there
[Music]
I have all these people watching and I'm
not even playing
because they're so high you were
welljust you can swap to my camera so
you can strong cravings oh my god I knew
reg still play
yeah man yeah correct so did
their belief may explain
wasn't even my fault I'd anything laying
properly
the word I mean it should have
Oh Oh
one that [ __ ] over oh oh thank you
[ __ ] a big box and he going to [ __ ] him
yeah I heard a gunshot
that's how you get sit down boys
god
[Music]
oh yeah you know what you're a much
nicer playing destiny this is bringing
the first time he's always really
bringing the worst out of your
personality I'd say that
we're going to the Brits
like oh wow all around hey I'm the one
that got her
my god
oh and I'm so glad I switched to your
camera witness yourself up I'm so glad I
switched it back now they did Oh
one more let's do one more a little more
god damn it yeah I'll do one more
that was [ __ ] ridiculous this time
hopefully later try to land this time
get away
I'd rather die I'd rather die right away
then get shot out of the car okay I'm up
there why I've been died on the side of
the road I'm ready to it should not
start annoying
I think this is it for me
that's one [ __ ] this alright that's
great let's make it a good one
and a fuel and we're already halfway to
the problem oh wait you guys acted like
you guys act like you finished in the
top ten after I died okay
I want to point out the last time we
played we almost [ __ ] won okay so
[ __ ] you wait what just happen I think I
got booted out no really it's a black
screen for all of us I think yeah we're
all actually jump back in I can't jump I
said no he's not over now he's on a
black screen well the game started over
yeah [ __ ] you should just hop right back
in the Harz
now you're gone he's gone we're gonna
have to get out that game yeah I'm gonna
quit it - it's like acting weird for me
now yeah let's let's just quit out and
start over the match is still in
progress do you want to continue I'm
gonna say yes yeah let's go cancel
cancel I say we get one [ __ ] Rumble
match in free-for-all we should all fall
try and find guns see who reigns supreme
a team player [ __ ] I [ __ ] not
helping your friends wait my club Jesus
and I got a kill start working that's
telling me to join up are you guys in
something way way way software they need
Griffin I get in it I got the munchies
so bad where should we we go so bad I
mean you have a problem
slash it is a problem one yeah what much
match is still in progress
what just has a cancel cancel
you didn't say cancel did you why now
wait wait now you want to lead us
[ __ ] my screen your dear alright
hold on hold on let me give me a sec now
let's start over then invite me I'm not
you can choose talking [ __ ] already what
to say yeah damn right
no be like oh is the where of greatness
be like a steroid a steroid Siri to
captain ko almost done more gamer we're
done are you talking we gonna start use
this prize this is like annoying hold on
connected huh I'm streaming when I hold
on I think I'm here it says you're here
you're like butt ass naked on the screen
your team a new team is eliminated okay
whatever
but I'm here so are we ready let's go
you here should we say start yeah yeah
you see here you want trying to
broadcast again I gotta push up trying
to clean to zone but I'm not sure if
there is what is she supposed to check
for Griffin
you ever look like he's about to be
upset that she took the last Oreo you
know what shut your bald face okay
haha Frank is 24 with his head like some
shaved monkey legs I'm turning 29 into
this month actually Oh a birthday here
bro
I was I was helping you out by making
you 24 come on captain coke and of
course I'm still I'm still on a player
battle bounce you guys aren't in the
plane huh
great [ __ ] load gonna [ __ ] look
I'm not in this game [ __ ] it up is
there there we go I'm in now if you stop
what I was looking at I might have to
leave right mommy are we parachuting
yeah we're person yeah when did you
already leave oh my god oh there you are
less you go what do we have to say more
than go to get you they see how coke
changes these County changes when some
let's be bearish you doubt once we
parachute out yeah coke is like [ __ ]
Rambo and [ __ ] in the city but look a
lone wolf man pop pop your parachute and
then just aim towards us I did what you
guys are like okay
wait oh my god they had anybody here I'm
never gonna make it you guys oh my god
whoa we don't we don't have anybody here
so you should be okay far away from ya
take a picture of that oh my god I'm so
far away from you guys I'm gonna die
okay here we go I'm running I'd have two
worst guns dude hey man I'm in like a
field okay that sounds about where most
of us I'm so far away marathon bro god
dammit I get the worst that's such a
relationship you know you're not you're
not that fast okay thank you thanks for
the game encourage their runs out you
know you're obviously compensating by
playing these NBA games what the [ __ ]
did you guys always run to every [ __ ]
thing cuz we loop fast Craig do you take
like golly I'm a salute
house hung a pillbox it takes Kraig
[ __ ] five minutes just to [ __ ] see
what's on the shelf okay all right I got
a gun I'm ready to go where are you guys
where are we oh we're in the zone which
we had next we should go head to where
I'm head
oh there's like a energy drink yes well
that plane is soaked all right now I'm
not gonna [ __ ] what am i father now what
a nightmare following you imagine
following Craig like oh I'm gonna go
ahead you go you go you are not gonna
come yes there you go you're fun I'm
gonna go to these two houses I'm gonna
go this little shack right here it is a
backpacking here I'm pretty sure yeah
but Craig didn't get lit the [ __ ] up
right now
[Laughter]
Craig's about to go [ __ ] die and
there's why are you following him your
[ __ ] face because I'm gonna back him
up so oh now you all be agony you know
what this is feeling a little racial now
so you gonna back up Craig I was right
here with you what is that
he's we were down to the final 70 he did
backed me up yeah this is a whole no oh
my god I backed you up
I just don't make terrible decisions
that's the difference you're making a
terrible decision right now you want to
wait for me you're doing it right now
if you run me over I swear to God
sorry our that works you packing box
well that car works did you guys get the
box yeah I got it
no [ __ ] way what'd you get
Hey look don't hide into my girl no
we're not looking just tell us what
you're trying to play yeah hey I got a
15-time scope if somebody wants it I'll
tell ya I don't know if I can use it
there's some kind of what is this I got
first aid kit that's Frank it's Frank
you just can't tell us yeah Frank you
want to tell us what's going on yeah
Frank pulled up on us like immigration
wanted us to know how it felt
[Laughter]
why would he give me a 15-times smooth
this whole gun that I can use it with
sorry tough let's go
I got the I got up G you can put the 15
Scott time scope on that Craig it's not
letting me do it
I'm telling you I can't equip it what
doesn't work Craig guys he's the first
guy I'm looting
I like your attitude sometimes Frank
wait should I get the car bring it over
there now it's kind of hard to go
through this [ __ ] plate let's just
leave it there
this fuck-ups this [ __ ] side you're
gonna get it trapped in this [ __ ]
swamp man I'm just gonna drive right
here to the side of the road right next
to it there's a level two backpacker and
you don't want it no I have one all
right somebody somebody needs to take
this there's a shock that at level 15 oh
just give me the 115th scope yeah well
I'm taking this factor here I'm dropping
it right here I dropped it Jesus that
thing's a [ __ ] monster bro I can't
put that on me I can't use it on my gun
I've got a nice weapons situation I can
see through someone's [ __ ] soul with
this scope hey do you have any did you
get any other scopes I got a red dot
I'll take it this this scope is [ __ ]
nuts dude holy [ __ ] welcome check out
these houses over here I don't know how
I feel about this thing this thing's
almost too much no no wait why okay all
right let's go home
frank says going coming going solo over
here come pick me up if she goes can did
Frankie way over there we have a [ __ ]
farm
[Music]
this is running the whole time
oh yeah yeah yeah
tryin kind of become people get back in
get back in there
anybody in here no oh oh nice first date
I need that all right I got a a km you
know I'm gonna switch this I'm gonna
switch this for the cam I like they can
be better
what do you drop them vector we played
it enough to know what their call could
use a vast desert best in here was the
level own engineers I'll come there you
know I got none all right Frank's a nap
what are you doing
[Music]
they're gonna let people know where we
are
you're leaving with leavin coat huh wait
over there
owns it what are you doing it's not way
over here you get better guns
[Music]
sometimes got to carry this team
and there's gonna be people there's
gonna be people coming because level-3
backpack here's a level-two backpack why
do you know you're gonna take it there's
a level - I got it should be able to see
everything you got like a movie that I
can see through Souls let's go Frank
come on Frank sorry I'm gonna come one
walked past a level three vest I know I
dropped a level three decks for my level
two baths
Stevie Wonder fell we gotta get in the
circle yeah we gotta get in the circle
bro wait that the circle hasn't even
started moving these are hoping we've
been doing they're open what are you
doing yeah I was there
mark somewhere let's go here it is three
marks right here you want the blue I do
you want to go go here on this rage too
many people on that ride straight ahead
and marker it's not even [ __ ] showing
up on my my own compass right here right
on d-pad won't take them out
we gotta press it to switch between the
different ones to toggle the communal
that's my [ __ ] right there to press
widened which to you if you get in our
scopes let me know any better scopes I'm
gonna put this 15 times and then we'll
put the two time this that is you you
Frank yeah there's an ache a over here
yes there's a hem 16 over here was the
VSS here too
no no you just equip it you're not
equipping on your gun
Frank did you take that VSS no I'll take
the VSS then where were you at a K all
right Merry Christmas
straight ahead straight ahead I'll take
your ammo oh you will huh
and I'll drop you all that bro I don't
have any [ __ ] ham what the [ __ ]
9 mil you know I made 9 mil no I have 9
mil but I dude I swear I had [ __ ] amo
for that a K we haven't seen one person
that this is insane lucky
I don't think we should take the car
right do we want to do that now not
anymore
that's one circle I say push up to these
buildings the northeast of us I think we
should hold it down
listen we should hold this down and so
on alright else we'll do this one and
then let's hold this down I don't know
why either okay
car to the west doors to the I don't
think these have been [ __ ] with no
level feedback painkiller
yeah take all the health stuff that you
have a room oh it was good what happens
what happens I see some vehicles over
here we prefer shotguns oh that's me
dope or you shoot I'm changing I'm
changing this 15 times go shotguns shows
hey I'll take it
really if you don't want dude it's so
slow you can't like their [ __ ]
it's up lights up here yeah there's some
762
oh you're the furniture are we did you
check the houses next door already
I was across the way I'm just gonna hold
in here
we got to move already
oh yeah oh this one that one circle
there's a jeep over here over here we
can grab there's two of them one take it
yeah we do dude we're pretty far and
there's gonna be a lot of [ __ ] that's me
that's me all right fine
where are you Cove gonna hit gonna hit
this [ __ ] can you pick me up I'll keep
scoping
all right let's go friend
[Music]
should we grab that car on the Left have
two vehicles no the French live in let's
go let's go Oh
which asked us to play fortnight
that's sure they do
we're gonna be people on that [ __ ]
Mountain guarantee dude
come around we're never [ __ ] sick of
it right now out what right ahead of us
all the stuff gonna be in that place
over there now Jesus I hate this [ __ ]
thing
yeah that's what I'm
let's go to the one with the garages and
it's got like
the top spot yep careful there's a lot
there's open doors well you get out of
the car bbbb go cute in here
yep here it's up for Gryffindor see in
this house it's clear check upstairs
I'm checking
let's do it it's Gucci we're good don't
be you know be holy be a whole system it
stopped over there
that garage there's a holographic sight
in here just in case two of the circle
goes oh right on us boys good [ __ ]
oh boy here we go this means they're
gonna come this way lay low lay low
yeah if you spot him let me know I got
this 15 I feel like I feel like Frank
and I should be top you guys should be
bottom awesome ice castle Griffin
Griffin hold this door with me bike
behind us three of them
what did that yellow house be ready
they're gonna they're gonna go down
there boys oh [ __ ] oh Jesus Christ
I see one I see one he's right behind
this thing yeah see
always behind that thing go get him yep
I'm pushing right come with me
help me
where's yet they're all in here come on
I got you you got it why is this duel
sorry about that I just didn't see where
is that cuz I came out to make sure we
can help keep it on the back end oh
where is that we're getting dumped on my
sniper I'm going yeah I'm going back
inside
oh here comes oh here comes a [ __ ]
where is that behind us is but it's
behind us yeah
some people just go into that house
behind us but I don't have a [ __ ]
scope the people are in that house like
where I'm going to store this door over
here
195 75 90 behind this east east there
they got achievement yeah there's a Jeep
in front of the house I hit a guy still
in the circle boys well where's were
they Adams behind this tree he's behind
us trees 75 by this Jeep
good deal I [ __ ] Hyman on the road no
yeah wait mine's a dream use an energy
drink see when the jeep entry to the
right at about 80 he was right there I
hit him I hit him earlier careful
careful
oh you saw me taking out their [ __ ]
cheese [ __ ] them come across one by a
tree 40 40
I see him I've been shooting at him he
dumped behind that [ __ ] tree watch
out watch out Griffin there shoot there
sniping at you close the door close the
door close the door no no no don't don't
you yeah yeah yeah yeah it's [ __ ]
sniping a hardcore through this one
anybody got heels I do I do I do we have
a first-aid kit I'm gonna drop the
first-aid kit
energy drink here's the energy careful
watch the nice windows trying dude good
grab my [ __ ] yeah he just got my
helmet like crazy yeah I need a new
helmet my shits [ __ ] come on guys
Carrie you disappeared okay blue lines
coming in where we're still good though
oh we're gonna have to move oh [ __ ]
I'm almost dead oh [ __ ] I gotta use
something all over here good care of the
bandage painkiller careful the door
somebody watch that door my god this is
this is thank you
oh man C&D I gave you all my [ __ ] coke
[ __ ] it's all good
I got bandages oh this thing is right
here
it's in the house of the guy at 17 huh
I need a [ __ ] helmet
I'm gonna jump on the window right here
as soon as we need to get in the circle
good job we're gonna have to move oh my
god this is a nightmare it won't have to
watch to our left
I think that's gonna get crazy yeah I
don't know yeah careful Oh oh [ __ ] I
thought that was one of you guys oh the
things moving what god he's right
outside by the garage coke behind you I
can't believe it but I oh man that guy
just was right there
I finished for good game plan - that
wasn't too bad
well said everybody let's try to sit
that's it for me happy should be happy
everybody's one you're dead you got
there no girl that we're tuning into you
get massacred
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]